[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم مشاهدينا انها الساعه ستون
برنامج اخباري خاص ومتنوع وبايقاع سريع
ومختلف جدا نحلل الاحداث بابعادها وبعمق
وبين العاجل والمهم نضع امامكم الاهم
والصوره الكامله البدايه من العناوين بعد
300 ساعه تحت الانقاض الركام تخرج معجزات
وبعد 12 يوما اعاده الاعمار الهاجس الاكبر
حرب المناطيض والاجسام الغريبه وجه جديد
للصراع المشتعل بين بكين وواشنطن تفكير
امريكي خارج الصندوق من خارج الكوكب
وفي ملفات الساعه 60 بعد خمسه اشهر على
تفجيرها من بنما تتكشف اسرار ضرب خطوطي
انا
في ايراننا ووسط معاناه المواطنين وتلمح
الاقتصاد هناك ميزانيه بالدولار لا تمس
الميليشيات تنال حصتها
[موسيقى]
13 يوما مرت على وقوع الزلزال المدمر الذي
ضرب تركيا وسوريا على عتبه اسبوعين
الحصيله ليست نهائيه العدد الكلي للضحايا
في البلدين وصل اليوم الى اكثر من 46 الفا
تمر الايام الساعات والثواني نحو انعدام
الامل في ايجاد نجيب ربما تكتب
الاكثر تضررا بين المقاطعات التركيه نهايه
معجزات الكارثه ثلاثه اشخاص تم انقاذهم
اليوم كما نتابع قضى من بينهم طفل في
المستشفى نجا اثنان حتى الان بعد 300 ساعه
قضاياها تحت الانقاض وكثيره هي الماسي
التي نتجت عن زلزال تركيا سوريا اسوا
كارثه منذ قرن مئات الالاف من الناجنه
مشردون والاف الاطفال الابرياء بات مصيرهم
العراء واليتم منهم من تركوا بلا هويه او
اسم مسؤول الصحه في تركيا وسوريا يحاولون
مطابقه الاطفال مجهولين هويه بالعناوين
لكن اي عناوين بعد ان طمست ملامح البيوت
في مدينه اسكندرون المنكوبه مثلا هناك
اكثر من 260 طفلا مصابا لم يتم التعرف
عليهم بعض الاطفال حتى لا يستطيعون نطق
اسمائهم الصدمه النفسيه كانت شديده بحسب
احدى عاملات الاغاثه في بلده جنديرس وبعض
اخر في سن مبكره ويصعب اصلا التواصل معهم
هكذا تؤكد احدى متطوعات تقدم الدعم النفسي
والاجتماعي للقصر في شمال غرب سوريا
اطفال مجهولون الهويه هم ضحايا الزلزال
المميته في تركيا كتبت لهم النجاه لكنهم
فقدوا ذويهم ولا يمكن التعرف على هويات
معظمهم حتى الان الارقام الرسميه ذكرت
قرابه 1400 طفل تم انقاذهم دون التعرف على
ذويهم في بدايه الامر لكن السلطات استطاعت
تحديده الف منهم ونجحت الجهود في لم شمل
500 طفل مع اسرهم وتم تحويل البقيه الى
المشاكل لتلقي العلاج وزاره الاسره
والخدمات الاجتماعيه استضافت 200 طفل لم
يتم التعرف على هويتهم حتى اللحظه مجلس
البحث العلمي والتقني التابع لبرنامج
التعرف على الوجوه في تركيا استطاع لوحده
تتبع هويات
144 طفلا وجاري العمل على تتبع هويات
البقيه
السؤال الان ما هو مصير هؤلاء الاطفال
وزاره الاسره والخدمات الاجتماعيه في
تركيا تشير الى انه في حال انتهت جميع
محاولات التوصل لاسرهم واقاربهم سيقيم
هؤلاء الاطفال في دور رعايه تابعه للدوله
او لدى اسر حاضنه الوزاره تلقت بالفعل
اكثر من خمسه وتسعين الف طلب بهذا الشان
لكن هناك شروط فيما يخص تركيا ان يكون
المحتضن مواطنا تركيا ويقيم داخل البلاد
ان يتراوح عمره بين 25 و 65 عاما وان يكون
حاصلا على مؤهل تعليمي وان يكون لديه دخل
منتظم هذه الطلبات الكثيره علقت عليها
منظمه انقذ الاطفال بانها ليست الحل
الفوري في هذا الوقت في التبني لا يجب ان
يحدث مباشره بعد حالات الطوارئ التي تنتج
عن الكوارث وفي ظل الانشغال الكبير لانقاذ
ما يمكن لانقاذه من تحت الركام اخر خطر
يخص مستقبل هؤلاء الاطفال امكانيه
استغلالهم من قبل عصابات خطف الاطفال
والاتجار بالبشر نداءات حقوقيه تحذر من
مصير بائس لهم التحذير ذاته شدد عليه
الاختصاصي بقسم الطوارئ في منظمه يونسف في
هذا النوع من الكوارث كوارث الاطفال
الاطفال معرضون للعنف والاستغلال وسوء
المعامله بما في ذلك خطر الاتجار او العنف
القائم على الجنس
من لندن تنضم الينا ريبيكا سميث مديره
برنامج حمايه الطفل بالانابه اهلا بك اذا
الكارثه لم تجنب احدا الماسي لكن الاطفال
هم الاكثر هشاشه والاكثر التضررا كيف يمكن
ضمان عدم استغلال الاطفال خاصه مجهول
الهويه منهم في تركيا بعد كارثه الزلزال
من مصير يهدد مستقبلهم وربما حياتهم
على استضافه والتحدث معي نعم من اهم
الاشياء التي نضع عليها اولويه كبيره هي
اين هو مصير هؤلاء الاطفال الذين انفصلوا
عن اهلهم كيف يمكن تسجيلهم وكيف يمكن
دعمهم وتقديم الرعايه اليهم من قبل
المجتمع وهذه مساله كنا قد رايناها في
كوارث متعدده في انحاء مختلفه من العالم
ومساله جوهريه تقتضي ضروره تنسيق
استجاباتنا
والسعي من ان كافه اللاعبين والجهات
الفاعله سوف يعملون فيما بينهم بهذا
الاتجاه
نعم كان هناك بعض الملاحظات على الاجراءات
او على الشروط التي وضعتها وزاره الاسره
والخدمات الاجتماعيه من قبل سيف ذا تشيدرن
انقذ الاطفال برايك ما الذي يجب ان يعني
ما هي الشروط التي يجب ان توضع في هذا
التوقيت وهل ينفع ان يتم التبني الان ام
هؤلاء الاطفال يحتاجون الى اعاده تاهيل
ربما
انه لا يمكن اجراء عمليات التبني في عقب
الزلزال لاننا ما زلنا نسعى للعثور على
اهالي هؤلاء الاطفال وتسجيلهم ونتعقب
اماكن ندويهم من خلال منظمات عالميه
ومحليه وبعض الجهات التي تبحث عن هؤلاء
الاطفال احيانا قد ترون بعض الاخبار التي
تقوم باعطاء مؤشر عن بعض افراد اسرته
هؤلاء الاطفال ونعلم انه في اعقاب الكوارث
فان كل هؤلاء الضحيه سوف يكون لهم اقارب
ومن اسرهم ويمكنهم ان يقدموا الدعايه
والرام كلا فنحن لا نقترح بان يتم اجراء
التبني كخيار ما بل نضع اولويه على
تسجيلها الى الاطفال
وتقديم الدعم للمقدمين الرعايه والافرادي
الاسره
والتحقق من ان هذا العمل يتم بصوره منسقه
لانه حتى لو فقد طفلا ما في منطقه ما يمكن
العثور على طفلين اخرين في منطقه ثانيه
اذا شكرا جزيلا لك كنت معنا
مديره برنامج حمايه الطفل بالانابه
[موسيقى]
كثيره هي المناطق التي نكبت بسبب الزلزال
الكارثه الانسانيه بسبب هذه الازمه هي
الاساس لكن ترافقها ضخامه التاثيرات اعاده
البناء في المناطق المنكوبه ستستغرق وقتا
وعلى الاقل عقد من الزمن هايتي لا تزال
تعاني من زلزال 2010 وتحاول اعاده الاعمار
دمى زلزال فيها 60% من النظام الصحي اعيد
بناء بعض المستشفيات لكنها حتى الان لا
تعمل بكامل طاقتها التشغيليه بسبب النقص
في المواد والموظفين الخوف في تركيا من
مصير مشابه فاينل شيل تايمز وصفت جهود
اعاده الاعمار التي ستبدا بها تركيا بانها
الاكبر منذ تاسيس الجمهوريه عام 1923
فالتكلفه الاوليه تقدر بمئه مليار دولار
تكلفه كبيره لان الخسائر الاقتصاديه كانت
ضخمه وتصل الى 84 مليار دولار بحسب اتحاد
الشركات والاعمال التركيه بنك جيبي مورين
قدرات التكلفه الاوليه للخسائر بانها
تعادل 2.5% من الناتج المحلي الاجمالي
لتركيا المناطق التي ضربها الزلزال تحتاج
الى 16 مليار دولار لتشييد المباني
المدمره فقط فيها كل هذه الخسائر ستؤثر
بالتالي على عجز الموازنه والمرجح ان
يرتفع من 3.5% الى
5.4% لكن الصوره ليست قاتمه بالمطلق في
اعاده الاعمار ما قد يثير الدهشه في احيان
كثيره هو السرعه الكبيره التي تتعافى بها
البلدان من الحاله حاله الدمار بسبب
الكوارث وهكذا يرى الامر الفيلسوف
الاقتصادي البريطاني جون ستورت ميل طبعا
يختلف حسب حجم الكارثه والاقتصاد المحلي
والقاعده السكانيه وبالطبع المنطقه
الجغرافيه المتاثره دراسه نشرتها الامم
المتحده في وقت سابق اكدت ان الكوارث
الطبيعيه هي فرصه لاعاده البناء بشكل افضل
وتحقيق قفزه تنمويه من خلال بنيه تحتيه
متطوره لم تكن لتوجد في غياب الكارثه
خصوصا مع وجود اموال المساعدات في تركيا
وكما تحدثنا في حلقه الامس كان لديها عدد
كبير من المباني التي شيدت بشكل مخالف
خمسه وسبعون الف مبنى في مناطق الزلزال
فقط وهنا ترى الامم المتحده ان الامر
الايجابي الان هو تشييد مباني بشكل صحيح
وقانوني واكثر امتثالا لقوانين البناء
ضربت المنظمه مثالا ابي زلزاله ستوان عام
2008 في الصين كان بقوه 7.8 درجات حصيله
ضحاياه نحو
وذلك بسبب ضعف الامتثال لقوانين البناء
وبعدها تغيرت معايير السلامه في المقاطعه
الصينيه لكن دراسه اخرى للبنك الدولي
وصندوق النقد الدولي حذرت من امرا خطر
خلال عمليه اعاده الاعمار بدافع الحزن
والاسى قد يتم الاندفاع للعمليه دون وجود
مؤسسات مخصصه لذلك اندونيسيا نجحت في
تفادي هذا الامر بانشاء مؤسسه يقودها
خبراء ومختصين
كشفت اتحاد الشركات والاعمال في تركيا ان
تكلفه الضرر التي قد يتكبدها الاقتصاد
التركي بسبب الزلزال ربما تتجاوز 84 مليار
دولار وتمثل الولايات التي ضربها الزلزال
ما يقارب عشره في المئه من الناتج المحلي
الاجمالي للبلاد بينما قال البنك الاوروبي
لاعاده الاعمار والتنميه ان الزلازل قد
تتسبب في خساره ما يصل الى واحد في المئه
من الناتج المحلي الاجمالي للبلاد ويقدر
اقتصاديون ان زلزال سيخفض النمو الاقتصادي
بما يصل الى نقطتين مئويتين حيث توقعت
الحكومه في وقت سابق ان يشهد العام الجاري
نموا بنسبه 5.5
طبعا المساعدات الماليه كما ذكرنا هي جزءن
من الدعم الذي تستخدمه الدول المتضرره من
الكوارث في اعاده الاعمار جهات عند قدمت
مساعدات لسوريا وتركيا بعد الزلزال لكن
بجانب الدول هناك حملات جمع تبرعات من اجل
الضحايا ومن اجل اعاده الاعمار مثلا في
تركيا جمعت حمله تركيا قلب واحد اكثر من
سته مليارات دولار في بث مباشر على الهواء
في سبع ساعات فقط سوريا الى جانب تبرعات
دول وهيئات حول العالم لاجئون بالملايين
سوريون ثلاثه عشره مليونا حول العالم حاول
بعضهم المساعده في ولايه تنسى اللاجئ
السوري ياسين تيرو جمع اكثر من
186 الف دولار لاغاثه المتضررين من
الزلزال ومن بينها مواد غذائيه ياسين لم
يكتفي بذلك بل ذهب لتركيا من اجل توزيع
المساعدات وضمان وصولها لمستحقيها بعضها
يتم كما ذكرنا في حلقه الامس رحله ياسين
تابعتها كاميرا الساعه ستون
[موسيقى]
اذا سنعود الى الشرق الاقتصادي من ملفنا
وينضم الينا فيها الخبير الاقتصادي التركي
الدكتور
رحمي عن جكاره اهلا بك دكتور الى اي مدى
يمكن ان يكون تعهد اردوغان باعاده الاعمار
خلال عام واقعيا خاصه مع هذا الحجم الكبير
من الخسائر وايضا نتحدث عن 85 مليار دولار
والتكلفه الاوليه للاعمار تقدر بمئه مليار
دولار
خلال زيارته الثانيه الى المناطق التي
ضربها الزلزال
بعض المناطق المتضرره الاخرى
فكان هناك
حديث عن ضروره قيام
البلاد بعمليه اعاده اعمار
لعدد كبيره من المباني الامر الذي يتطلب
مواد خرسانيه طائله وحتى اللحظه فان
التقديرات تشير الى ان ان المبالغ قد
تتغير في ظل
وجودي عدد كبير من المساكن التي التي تم
بناؤها بطرق مخالفه لذا فانك التقديرات
تشير الى 100 مليار دولار لاعاده الاعمار
بالاضافه الى ما خلفه الزلزال من اثار على
الاقتصاد
الامر يتطلب اعاده بناء مستشفيات وطرق
وبنى تحتيه التي التي تضررت ايضا على على
المدى
المباشر في عقب الزلزال وهناك ضروره
لاستثمار مئه مليون دولار اخرى ايضا في
البنى التحتيه
ولابد ايضا من التخصيص الميزانيه لاصلاح
منازل كثيره تضررت
وقد تصل قيمتها الى 87 مليون دولار
وبالنسبه لتركية التزم البنك الدولي بواحد
فاصل ثمانيه مليون دولار من خلال قمه تم
عقدها
وايضا بعض الشركات التجاريه الموجوده في
تركيا قدرت ان
ان العدد الاجمالي
المطلوب للاقتصاد التركيه هو 8.1 مليار
دولار من خلال تقييم ما خلفته الكارثه
وهذا ياخذنا بالرقم الى
تسعه فاصل تسعه مليار دولار
وهناك اكثر من 17 الف مواطن قد تضرروا في
في احدى الولايات لوحدها
لابد لنا ان نشير ايضا الى انخفاض متوقع
في حجم الناتج المحلي والنظر المستقبليه
للاقتصاد بواقع 5.5
وهناك تقديرات تشير
ان ان الزلزال قد خفض من هذه النظره
المستقبليه
بصوره اساسيه
وان النظره سوف تكون
النظره المستقبليه سوف تكون باتجاه
النزولي
الامر الذي سوف يضع ضغوطا على الحكومه
التركيه في اسطنبول الى جانب الارقام الى
جانب الارقام وهذه التكلفه المهوله
والحاجه هل تسمعني دكتور الى جانب كل هذا
هناك يعني هل هناك موارد كافيه نعلم ان
هناك مساعدات نعلم ان هناك قدره كبيره في
تركيا على اعاده الاعمار الان ولكن هل
هناك موارد كافيه وهل هناك خطه واضحه
لاعاده الاعمار نتحدث عن 500 كيلو متر من
الاراضي التركيه مدمره الان بالكامل وكما
ذكرت هي بنيه تحتيه هي مباني ليس فقط
مباني هي مباني وطرق وايضا مياه وتدفئه
وكل وكل ما يحتاجه المواطن للعيش في هذه
المدن المنكوبه
ضروري جدا ان يتم الوقوف على هذه على هذه
الاشياء وقال الرئيس اردوغان بانه سوف سوف
يتم رسم خطه للتعافي من
اثار هذا الزلزال في وخاصه في المناطق
الغربيه التي تضررت
واشار بانه سوف يتم سوف يتم التعافي
واكمال اعاده الاعمار خلال فتره قصيره من
الزمن
وايضا وزير
الشؤون الحضريه كان قد كرر
هذا الامر
وشدد على انه من الضروري ان
يتم وضعي معايير لمراقبه الزلازل في تركيا
فضلا عن ذلك يمكن لاثار هذا الزلزال ان
تطال ايضا قطاع الانتاج
الذي يؤدي الى اكثر من ثمانيه فاصل ثلاثه
في المئه في اجمال الناتج المحلي
وهذا الانخفاض في قطاع الانتاج سوف يكون
له اثر سلبي على
الاقتصاد في تركيا
بصوره مباشره وغير مباشره
لذا نعم وضحت الصوره
وضحت الصوره دكتور شكرا لك كنت معنا من
اسطنبول الخبير الاقتصادي التركي الدكتور
رحمي عن جكره
خطروا واصين يوحدوا الاراء في واشنطن في
الساعه بعد دقيقه
[موسيقى]
هنا في مدينه حلب السوريه المنكوبه بسبب
الحرب ثم الزلزال كل شيء يتحول من ماساويا
الى مفجع هذا المنزل كان مليئا بالحب
عروسان كان لتوهما قد تزوج لكن الزلزال لم
يمهلهما الوقت قضت عليهما الكارثه وما
تبقى من منزلهما هو هذه الحبال حبال
الزينه التي خلدت قصه حبهما وماساتهما في
ان واحد
هنا في مدينتي بنما مركز للغوص والانقاذ
التابع للبحريه الامريكيه يعمل على تدريب
الغواصين في المياه العميقه لدى المركز
مهمتين ازاله الحطام والذخائر غير
المنفجره في الموانئ والثاني وهو الاهم
تفجير انابيب النفط الاجنبيه المكان كان
مثاليا لتدريب الغواصين على مقاموا به في
سبتمبر الماضي تفجير خط انابيب
اثنين في سبتمبر 2022 هكذا يؤكد تحقيق
استقصائي للصحفي سيمون هيرش ومن اجل تنفيذ
هذا التفجير بحث بايدن وفريقه الترتيبات
سريه لاكثر من تسعه اشهر والاساس كانت
تنفيذ دون تركي اي دليل عن المسؤول في
ديسمبر 2021 عقد مستشار الامن القوميه
الجيك سولفن اجتماعا لفريق كان قد تم
تشكيله حديثا لمناقشه الرد على غزو الوشيك
لاوكرانيا احدى ردود كانت مناقشه خطه
لتدمير نورسرين الوجوه المؤثره في هذا
الاجتماع بجانب سالب كان وزير الخارجيه
بنكن ووكيله وزاره الخارجيه فيكتوريا
نولاند وثلاثه وجوه كانت ترى ان الخطه تفي
برغبات الرئيس بينما وصف المعارضون الامر
بانه كابوس سياسي اذا خرج للعلن وسيدخل
امريكا في الحرب ان حدثت على كل ان نفذت
الخطه وجزء منها كان اختيار خريجي مركز
الغوص في بنما لتنفيذ العمليه اختيار
مثالي ان كان المتدربون في هذا المركز
اعضاء في قياده العمليات الخاصه الامريكيه
فيجب ابلاغ الكونجرس بالعمليه السريه لكن
كونهم من القوات البحريه فهذا ساهم في
التنفيذ دون الرجوع للكونجرس وربما ما
يدعم تحقيق هرش جاء قبل الحرب باسابيع
وبعد الاجتماع الذي نشرنا اليه بشهر
وبشهرين على التوالي نولندا في يناير
وبايدن في فبراير من عام 2022 دعما وبشكل
علني ودون قصد تحقيق هرش
[موسيقى]
نفع البيت الابيض تحقيقا للصحفيه
الاستقصائيه الامريكيه سيمور هرش يزعم ان
واشنطن كانت وراء انفجارات انابيب الغاز
في نورد ستريم ووصفه بانه خاطئ كليا ومحضو
خيال استند بالاضافه الى مصادره الخاصه
التي رفض تسميتها على تصريحات اداره بايدن
قبل وبعد التفجير مثل تواعد الرئيس بايدن
بتعطيل الخط وتصريح وكيله وزاره الخارجيه
للشؤون السياسيه
استماع للجنه العلاقات الخارجيه بمجلس
الشيوخ والتي قالت فيه انها تعتقد ان
الاداره مسروره للغايه لمعرفه ان النود
ستريم 2 اصبح الان قطعه كبيره من المعدن
في اسفل البحر المتحدثات باسم مجلس الامن
القومي في البيت الابيض ادريان وصفت هذه
التقارير بالوهم الكاذب وانضم اليها عدد
من المتحدثين باسم وكاله المخابرات
المركزيه ووزاره الخارجيه الذين رفضوا
تقرير جمله وتفصيلا
كانت الخطه اشبه بوضع قنبله ذريه على
الارض في طوكيو واخبار اليابانيين باننا
سنقوم بتفجيرها هكذا يرى مصدر حضر هذه
الاجتماعات خطه التي لجات فيها واشنطن
للدنمارك والسويد والنرويج الاخيره تحديدا
كانت الاهم لاكثر من سبب الولايات المتحده
وسعت بشكل كبير خلال السنوات التي سبقت
الحرب تواجدها في النرويج بما في ذلك
قاعده غواصات جددت مؤخرا المحاره
والغواصون النرويجيون لديهم خبره في
التنقيب عن النفط والغاز في اعماق البحار
ويمكن ايضا الوثوق بهم للحفاظ على سريه
المهمه سبب اخر وهو ان المتفجرات كانت
بحاجه للتمويه بطريقه تجعلها تظهر لتقنيات
المراقبه الروسيه كجزء من الطبيعه
والنرويج هنا لديها الامكانيات التقنيه
لذلك جزء اخر مهم وهو المنفعه المتبادله
النرويج قد تستفيد بان تكون محطه بديله
للغاز الروسي الى اوروبا وبالمناسبه
تزامنت التفجيرات مع افتتاح بولندا
والنرويج لخطي انابيب البلطيق ينقل الغاز
النرويجي من بحر الشمال الى اوروبا عبر
الدنمارك امريكا هي الاخرى قد تستفيد
بكونها بديلا اخر في 2022 زادت الصادرات
الامريكيه من الغاز المسال لاوروبا
بالنسبه
137% مقارنه بالفين 2021 لكن امرا مهما
اخر يخص النرويج هو ان اوسلو كان لديها
الاجابه على سؤال مهم متى تجرى العمليه
الاجابه النموذجيه كانت في موعد ثابت منذ
21 عاما تدريبات بالتوبس في بحر البلطيق
غطاء مثالي للزرع المتفجرات
[موسيقى]
خلال التمرين الدوريه لحلف الناتو وصل
الغوصون الامريكيون من بنما وعملوا مع
زملائهم في النرويج تحت الماء زرعوا مواد
متفجره على خطوط الانابيب وكانوا في
انتظار الاوامر بالتفجير لكن حدثت مشكله
اخرى غير اب غير بايدن موعد التفجير وراى
ان العمليه بعد ايام من التمرين سيظهر ذلك
واشنطن سيظهر ذلك واشنطن على انها متورطه
وهنا جاء طلب جديد للبيت الابيض زرع
المتفجرات مع التفجير عن بعد في وقت لاحق
غضب الغواصون لكن كان عليهم التنفيذ
ووجدوا الحل سيتم التفجير بواسطه عوامه
سونار تسقطها طائره ميزه هذه العوامه انه
انها تصدر اشارات قويه يمكن التعرف عليها
بواسطه الاجهزه المتصله بها وبالفعل تمت
الخطه في السادس والعشرين من سبتمبر قامت
طائره استطلاع من نوع p8 وهي تابعه
للبحريه النرويجيه قامت برحله روتينيه
اسقطت عوامه سونار تحت الماء في نولد
ستريم اثنين ثم واحد بعد بضع ساعات تم
التفجير فجرت ثلاثه من اربعه خطوط في غضون
دقائق وطبعا النتيجه تسرب كميات هائله من
غاز الميثان وهو احد اطول غازات ادفيئه
يسخن يسخن الغلاف الجوي حوالي 30 مره اكثر
من ثاني اكسيد الكربون والكارثه على
البيئه طبعا كبيره يكفي ان تعرف ان
التقديرات تشير الى ان التسرب ساوى حجم
انبعاثات غاز الميثان لمده عام كامل
وللتقريب الصوره يغطي مدينه بحجم باريس
طبعا كل هذه التسريبات نفتها واشنطن بينما
حاولت موسكو الضغط من خلالها على مجلس
الامن الدولي
[موسيقى]
من جناب ينضم الينا الدكتور حسني عبيدي
الاستاذ بجامعه جناب ومدير مركز الدراسات
في الابحاث حول العالم العربي والمتوسط
اهلا بك دكتور دكتور يعني
تم عن عمد في خطوط ستريم ولكن ايضا
الولايات المتحده تنفي الاتهامات راينا
وسمعنا تفاصيل هذا التحقيق الاستقصائي هل
يمكن ان تكون لديها ادله النرويج السويد
والدنمارك او من يملك الادله على هذه
التفجيرات
يعني الشيء المؤكد الى حد الساعه هو ان
هذا العمل هو عمل يعني عمل تفجيري وعمل
مدبر ويعني ليس لديه اي علاقه بحادثه
عرضيه هذه النقطه الاولى المسلمه لكن من
يقف وراء هذا الحادث من الصعب جدا باعتبار
ان الدول التي قالت بانها ستحقق مثل
النرويج والدنمارك وحتى المانيا باعتبار
ان المانيا لديها الحق قانونيا لانه هي في
النهايه زبون مثل روسيا ان تحقق كل هذه
التحقيقات لم تؤدي الى شيء اما روسيا كذلك
قانونيه لديها الحق لان هي دوله دوله
المصدر كذلك فقالت بان بعد شهر من الحادث
لم تبقى اي اثار لهذه العمليه وقالت بان
عمليه اجراميه اعتقد القضيه الان هي ستصبح
قضيه قانونيه مجلس الامن يمكن ان يتحرك
لكن وهي تطلب الان من مجلس الامن تحقيقا
مستقلا في تفجير نورت ستريم لبى دعوه
روسيا خاصه وان التصويت المطلوب من روسيا
يتزامن مع الاجتماعات للجمعيه العامه
ولاحياء الذكرى السنويه على الحرب الروسيه
الاوكرانيه
يعني صحيح من مصلحه روسيا في النهايه ان
تعيد هذه القضيه الى الواجهه
يعني سيخدمها دبلوماسيه سيخدمها
الاقتصاديه في تلك الفتره لم يكن في مصلحه
روسيا ان تفجر
واحد واثنين لكن هناك دول اخرى من
الولايات المتحده اوكرانيا لديها مصلحه
كبيره في التفجير وروسيا وصلت الى قناع
نفادها بانه لا يمكن لاي دوله من دول
البلطيق ولا اي الدوله المعنيه ان تقوم في
النهايه بتحقيق مستقل بقي لها الى مجلس
الامن هي تعلم كذلك جيدا بان مجلس الامن
من الصعب ان يتحرك في حضور الولايات
المتحده وكذلك بريطانيا وفرنسا لذلك ماذا
يمكن ان تكون الخيارات الاخرى يعني باي
اتجاه يمكن ان تذهب موسكو اذا رفض مجلس
الامن او اذا تم الاعتراض على بشان تحقيق
مستقل
يعني ستقوم روسيا يعني بما تعطيل اي
مشاريع اخرى مشابهه وتستعمل كذلك حق النقل
لكن ليس لديها قدره كبيره على الانتقال
الى عين المكان باعتبار كما قلت انه من
الصعب الان ايجاد اي اي ادله الدامغه تثبت
تورط الولايات المتحده او اي دوله او دوله
اخرى وبالتالي تبقى في النهايه فقط ابواب
الاشاعه مفتوحه تحقيق وتحقيق جيد لمنارش
معروف انه لديه مصادر مهمه جدا حتى داخل
الاداره الامريكيه لكن بمصدر واحد فقط
وغير معلن من الصعب جدا على اي جهه قضائيه
او حتى على مجلس الامن ان يتحرك بقي روسيا
كذلك الابواب القضائيه يمكن ان تقوم بدعوه
قضائيه لكن لا يمكن ان تكون هناك اي بعد
لا يكون بعد دولي لتحرك قضائي وهو بير
تقوم بروسيا فقط نعم شكرا جزيلا لك كنت
معنا من جناب الدكتور حسني عبيدي الاستاذ
بجامعه جنيب ومدير مركز الدراسات والابحاث
حول العالم العربي والمتوسط
[موسيقى]
اخيرا وبعد اسابيع انهت واشنطن اليوم
الذي اسقط قباله الساحل الشرقي لامريكا
لكن ماذا بعد القطعه الاخيره من الحطام
ستنقل الى المختبر التابع لمكتب التحقيقات
الفيدرالي في فرجينيا من اجل التحقيق وهنا
سيتم معرفه ان كان المنطاد استخدم للتجسس
ام لا بكين تنفي طبعا وتقول انه مدني لكن
قصه المنطاد فتحت الباب امام امر اخر
السمن غريبه في السماء في عدد من الدول
ومنها امريكا وكندا وحتى الصين خلال
الاسبوع الحالي فقط رصدت ثلاثه اجسام
غريبه في اجواء امريكا الشماليه حتى
اسقطتها الطائرات الامريكيه ولا تعلم
واشنطن بعد ماهيتها لكن مقابل اتهامات
واشنطن هناك اخرى بالعكس مناطيض امريكيه
دخلت المجال الجويه الصيني اكثر من عشر
مرات منذ يناير من العام الماضي
قدموا لنا تفسير وهذا ما تريده اقدم لنا
تفسير هذا ما تريده الصين من امريكا كل
هذه الاتهامات المتبادله ومنها طبعا ما له
علاقه بالتجسس لكن قائد القياده الشماليه
كان له راي اخر وخارج الصندوق من خارج
الكوكب
بعد الجدل الذي اثاره تصريح قائد القياده
الشماليه الامريكيه الجنرالندي بانه لا
يستبعد بان تكون الاجسام المجهوله التي
اسقطتها مؤخرا قادمه من خارج الكوكب اكد
البيت الابيض انه ليس هناك اي مؤشر على
انشطه لكائنات فضائيه خلال عمليات اسقاط
الاجسام الثلاثه لكن الجدل حولها مستمر
سياسيا فالجمهوريون صعدوا من انتقادهم
لتاخر الرئيس بايدن باسقاط المنطاد الصيني
كما انتقدوه ايضا في موضوع الاجسام
المجهوله لتاخره بتوجيه خطاب للامريكيين
لشرح ما حصل وحاولت الاداره الامريكيه
تهدئه احباط اعضاء مجلس الشيوخ بشان
المنطاد ونقص المعلومات حول الاجسام
المجهوله بتقديم احاطه سريه لاطلاعهم على
اخر التطورات لكن معظم الاعضاء خاصه
الجمهوريين خرجوا من الاحاطه باسئله اكثر
من المعلومات كما قالوا ليبقى الغموض يلف
الاجسام المجهوله
بعد حادثه من طاد الصين عدل الجيش
الامريكي نظام الرادار لجعله اكثر حساسيه
نتيجه لذلك زاد عدد ما تم رصده كما ذكرنا
ظهرت ثلاثه اجسام غريبه اخرى لكن لماذا
عدلت واشنطن الانظمه الان شعرت بالاحراج
من تكرار الامراض الاول مثلا ظل في السماء
لمده اسبوع كامل حسابات الولايات المتحده
مع الصين باتت اكثر تعقيدا مقارنه بحبها
البارده مع موسكو سلاح الاقتصاد الذي مثل
افضليه كبرى لواشنطن على حساب الشيوعيه
السوفييتيه فيما مضى بات اليوم يعطي
افضليه لبكين فمحاولات واشنطن لن تنجح في
فصل اقتصادها عن الصين من خلال وسائل
السياسيه مثل قيود السفر وحظر التكنولوجيا
والحواجز التجاريه ومن يقول ذلك مستشار
الامن القومي ومناسق البيت الابيض للقضايا
اسيا والمحيط الهادئ فقال مشترك لجيك صلب
نشرته فورن ايفرز في اكتوبر
وتسعه عشر وحتى التعريفات الجمركيه قد
تصبح ميزه للصين على المدى الطويل عبر
دفعها للاعتماد الذاتي اكثر كما يحدث الان
في صناعه الرقائق يصعب على واشنطن تجاهل
حقيقه ان الصين هي ثاني اكبر حائز لسندات
الخزانه الامريكيه ومستثمر كبير في
الاوراق الماليه الامريكيه الاخرى وكما
كشفت الاعوام القليله الماضيه اقرب حلفاء
واشنطن ليسوا مستعدين لمواجهه الصين او
تفكيكها اقتصاديا على نطاق واسع ولنا في
عام 2020 مثال تفوقت الصين على واشنطن
باعتبارها الشريك التجاري الاكبر للاتحاد
الاوروبي وحتى على المستوى الشعبي لا يرى
المواطن الامريكي بكين كعدو مباشر كما راى
موسكو استطلاعا للرائي في نوفمبر الماضي
لا يؤيد الاغلبيه سيناريو التدخل المباشر
لردع الصين في حال مهاجمتها تايوان او
الاستثمار الطويل مدى للتنافس مع الصين
هذه الحقائق دفعت صناع القرار في واشنطن
لاستغلال هذه الازمات لانتقاد اداره بايدن
فيما يخص تساهل مع التهديد الصيني مدعومين
طبعا بوجهه النظر الشعبيه فعلى سبيل
المثال لا تزال بعض العناصر التنافسيه
الاساسيه في استراتيجيه الاداره الامريكيه
تقابل بعدم قبول شعبي من قبيل زياده
الميزانيه الدفاعيه واعاده توجيه الصناعه
الوطنيه وفرضي تعريفات الجمركيه على
السلعه الاستراتيجيه كالرقائق التي ينتجها
الحلفاء وتبني تحول عسكري الشامل وتقويض
تمني عفوا واعاده الانفتاح الاقتصادي
والتجاري على العالم مواجهه حزبيه بين
الجمهوريين والديمقراطيين اسفرت الاحداث
الاخيره الجمهوريون وعلى راسهم ترامب
بتغريداته عمله على تسجيل اهداف سياسيه ضد
اداره بايدن اتهموها بالضعف والتاخر في
حمايه امن الاراضي الامريكيه من التهديد
الصيني ليرد الديمقراطيون بدورهم عبر
البحث في صفحات الماضي القريب والكشف عن
تحليقي مناطيت صينيه مشابهه فوق الاراضي
الامريكيه خلال رئاسه
المناكات الحزبيه امر اعتيادي في امريكا
لكن اللافت كان توافق قسم مؤثر من
الديمقراطيين ديمقراطي الكونجرس مع
الاغلبيه الجمهوريه في معارضه زياره وزير
الخارجيه الامريكي بلينكن توافق اخر نادر
بين الحزبين الصين هي الدوله الوحيده التي
لديها نيه لاعاده تشكيل النظام الدولي
وتمتلك بشكل متزايد القوه الاقتصاديه
والدبلوماسيه والعسكريه
والتكنولوجيه للقيام بذلك
فاتوره دعم ايران لميليشياتها تضاهي
ميزانيات دول في الساعه
بعد دقيقه
[موسيقى]
بدات قليلا لكنها لم تنتهي فالقصه لم تكن
مجرد تظاهرات عابره الاحتجاجات في ايران
كانت في مرحله استراحه محارب انطلقت من
جديد على مدار الايام الماضيه وربما اكثر
الدلائل على صلابه هذه التظاهرات جاءت
خلال كلمه ابراهيم الرئيسي بمناسبه تولي
السلطه اختراق اختراق موقع التلفزيون
الايراني لمده 40 ثانيه وماذا ظهر بدلا من
كلمه رئيس الشعارات الحاضره منذ سبتمبر
الماضي المراه الحياه الحريه
والموت بخام
امام تضخما فاق الثلاثين في المئه للسنه
الثالثه على التوالي وطبقه متوسطه باتت من
الماضي نظام طهران مصرا على حل واحد وهي
معالجه الاعراض للاسباب
بالرفع من ميزانيه الدعايه والمؤسسات
الامنيه الميزانيه الجديده رفعت من
ميزانيه الحرس الثوري بقيمه 28% لتبلغ نحو
58 مليار دولار 30 مليار دولار منها مخصصه
لدعم اذرع ايران في الخارج من رواتب
وتسليح ودعايه البدايه من الرواتب يتقاضى
كل عنصر من ميليشيات ايران في سوريا مثلا
250 دولارا شهريا عناصر ميليشيا الحوثي
نحو 200 دولار اما متوسط رواتب عناصر
ميليشيا حزب الله اللبنانيه فيصل الى
2300 دولار شهريا الا انها بدورها تخلو من
العداله جمال الدين ابرو مساعد الرئيس
البرلمان الايراني استولى على جزء من
مرتبات ميليشيا ايران في اليمن والعراق
وسوريا وهو يحصل تحصل على ميزانيه احتسبت
فيها رواتب تتراوح بين 500 والف دولار
بينما لم تتجاوز الرواتب في الواقع 200
دولار اذا ما استثنينا طبعا عناصر حزب
الله فابروند اختلس نصف رواتب 200 الف
مقاتل تابع لميليشيا ايران في الشرق
الاوسط صفقه الكل صفقه الكل فيها مستفيد
فهو وعبر منصبه بالبرلمان لا يتدخل في
ميزانيه فيلق القدس بل يساهم في اطفاء
السريه عليها بينما يسمح له بالتصرف يسمح
له بالتصرف بحريه في رواتب الميليشيات في
الخارج هذه المعادله جاءت كنتيجه لمقتل
قاسم سليماني خليفته باتا غير قادر على
ضبط هذه المهام والنتيجه توزيع المهام على
شخصيات كثيره تت على السلطه وتتفق في
سعيها نحو الثراء
ميزانيه ميزانيه سنويه تفاصيلها تصنف
كاسرار للدوله وبعيدا عن المسائله لا تمسح
الازمه والتضخم مقومه بالدولار وسخاؤها
ازهر من اشياء كثيره رغم استشراء الفساد
الفوضى في لبنان وسوريا والعراق واليمن لم
تثقل كاهل الدول هذه الدول فقط فاتوره
فاتوره دعم ايراني ميليشياتها باتت تضاهي
ميزانيات دول الكبرى وللمقارنه يعادل ما
تنفقه ايران على ميليشياتها فقط كل عام 30
مليار دولار وهو ما يوازي الموازنه
السنويه لبلد مثل المغرب وضعف مجمل مداخل
تونس السنويه لضمان تدفق الاموال اقرت
طهران نظاما ماليا يختلف عن باقي الدول
ميزانيه ثانيه في بلد واحد الاولى ميزانيه
عامه للدوله تدفع بها الرواتب وتمول
الوزارات من خلالها في ذلك وزاره الدفاع
اما الثانيه ميزانيه موازيه مخصصه حصرا
للحرس الثوري ومؤسسات المرشد المفارقه ان
الموازنه الثانيه التي تمول الحرس الثوري
تفوق ضعفي الميزانيه المخصصه للشعب بلغت
هذا العام ثمانيه وستين مليار دولار وهي
بذلك تفوق ميزانيه الدفاع الروسيه التي
تخوض حربا في اوكرانيا بلغه الارقام لم
يبقى الكثير للشعب 80% من الايرانيين حسب
اخر الاحصاءات يقبعون تحت خط الفقر الذي
حدد بثلاث مئه وسته وعشرين دولار للعائله
المتوسطه 8 مرات اقل من رواتب ميليشيا حزب
الله ميزه اخرى رواتب الحرس الثوري
واستثمارات ذراعه الاقتصاديه خاتم
الانبياء معفيه من الضرائب السؤال عن
السبب قد يجلب المشاكل بدل الاجابات
للادعاء بان مقر خاتم الانبياء لم يدفع
ضرائب في السنوات الخمس الماضيه يجب عليك
تقديم وثائق بهذا الخصوص يجب عليك تقديم
الوثائق والا من الممكن ان يتم مقاضاتك لا
يمكنك اتهام مؤسسه رسميه في هذا البلد
بانها لا تدفع الضرائب دون تقديم
المستندات يجب عليك تقديم المستندات بهذا
الخصوص بعد هذا الاجتماع والا سيوجه مكتب
المدعي العام اتهامات جنائيه لذا يرجى
توخي الحذر
لنفترض ان طهران ستجمد الاموال الموجهه
للمليشيات لعام واحدا فقط الايرانيون
سيكونون المستفيد الاكبر ما يقرب من 68
مليار دولار سنويا كما قلنا مبلغ سيؤدي
ضخه في الاقتصاد الايراني الى تحقيق
معدلات نمو لم تشهد البلاد بما يستجيب
لمطالب الشعب التي يرفعها في المظاهرات
البدايه من ازمه المياه وصفها وزير ايراني
بخطر يفوق ما تشكله اسرائيل والثورات
الداخليه 50 مليون ايراني يعاني من العطش
البحر سيتحول الى حل لا الى تهديد وذلك
ببناء محطات محطات تحليات لمياه لمياه
البحر محطه قادره على انتاج 530 الف متر
مكعب يوميا اي 20% من احتياجات محافظه
طهران والثمن لن يتجاوز 230 مليون دولار
اولويه اخرى قطاع الصحه المريض بوصف
المنظمات الصحه العالميه البلد بحاجه الى
عشرات المستشفيات الصغيره من فئه 100 سرير
رواتب الميليشيات تبلغ مليار ونصف المليار
دولار تكفي لبناء 200 مستشفى لكل
التجهيزات اللازمه البنيه التحتيه مشكله
اخرى
18000 ايراني يذهبون ضحيه حوادث المرور
سنويا طهران تبني الطرقات لكن الجوده
غائبه ولذلك هي تحتل المرتبه 77 عالميا في
جوده الطرقات اموال القواعد العسكريه التي
شيدت تحت الارض تقدر بمليارات وهو ما يكفي
لتحسين ترتيب البلد في عده مراكز التعليم
الجامعات مشكله اخرى تسعه ملايين ايراني
يعانون من الاميه بحسب البرلمان الايراني
البلد يحتاج لبناء الاف المدارس في
المناطق البعيده تكلفه صناعه صاروخ فاتح
اربعه ملايين دولار تكفي لبناء مدرستين
بمواصفات دوليه كل هذه المشاريع بجانب
تطويرها للقطاعات فهي ستساهم في حل مشكله
البطاله التي تبلغ 10% بحسب الارقام
الرسميه
رغم انها محنه لكن كارثه الزلزال سيست في
اكثر من جانب وضد اكثر من جهه ومنها تزايد
العنصريه ضد اللاجئين السوريين من قبل
البعض لكن في الشده تظهر معادن الناس
كلمات اثبتها السوريون في الواقع من الان
وحتى الساعه المقبله انا حنين الشولي وهذه
الساعه
[موسيقى]
سوريا